et notre politique ce matin c'est
Stéphane Troussel Bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec mon président du conseil
départemental de la semaine
sauf que pour le moment les autres
est-ce que du coup c'est une idée qui
fait c'est
absolument pas
elle prend acte de la situation de la
situation dans le pays ça personne ne
peut rester insensible à ce qui se passe
actuellement avec cette extrême droite
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat quand le
deuxième personnage de l'État Monsieur
Larcher président du Sénat le lendemain
de ce qui s'est passé à Villepinte
évoque une provocation des militants
antiracistes et mets d'une certaine
manière sur un même plan cette
mobilisation et les coups donnés par les
militants de Zemmour et donc on voit
bien à quel point il y a une brutalité
extrême droite de la dernière chance
pour la gauche
il faut le reconnaître est dans une
situation
particulièrement difficile et donc il
faut il faut bouger les lignes il faut
faire en sorte que l'agression de veux
pas qu'elle soit dans le témoignage et
bien prenne ses raisons que ce truc
c'est visiblement en tout cas la belle à
l'idée d'une primaire n'était pas
inscrite dans le dans le dans les gènes
des dès le départ de la de la gauche il
comprit chez chez Anne Hidalgo qui a
encore quelques semaines sur ce même
plateau lors d'une émission d'être à
l'hôpital disais la primaire la primaire
c'est de cette artificielle et elle
jugeait que toute façon il fallait aller
jusqu'au bout du débat visiblement elle
a changé d'avis
élection présidentielle c'est une
élection de mouvement et donc il faut
tenir compte des situations il faut
savoir s'adapter et et le débat va
continuer mais enfin écouter s'il y
avait un ou une candidate de gauche qui
surpasse tous tous tous tous les autres
et enclenche une dynamique ce n'est pas
le cas ça te désespère les électeurs et
les électrices de gauche ça tu
désespères nos concitoyens alors même
que la situation du pays se sont s'est
fracturé se sont un certain nombre de
défi c'est
David qui
pour le moment
les électeurs de vous interpeller tous
les ai tous semaine après semaine sur la
situation à gauche s'il y avait un
candidat ou une candidate de gauche qui
était encore une fois loin devant si
l'un d'entre surpasse et tous les autres
et que une dynamique ce soit créé en
faveur de l'un ou de l'autre
il y a un candidat pour l'instant
pour le deuxième tour et on va
jusqu'à quand donc oui il fallait faire
mouvement oui il fallait prendre acte de
cette situation et elle en
responsabilité elle dit à l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui veulent participer la
gauche encore quelque chose à dire dans
ce pays enfin quand même face à
l'explosion des inégalités face à cette
question climatique face au défi du
grand âge est-ce que la face à la
situation de l'hôpital public au
lendemain de cette crise sanitaire
quels candidats de gauche aujourd'hui tu
arrives à Metz ces questions là dans les
bars c'est bien parce que il y a cette
extrême
dispersion émiettement de la gauche que
aucun des cons et la gauche aujourd'hui
et bien
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
nous éclairer sur la manière dont la
décision est prise à quel moment elle a
elle a changé d'avis ça s'est passé hier
avant-hier mais vous savez bien que ce
type de situation c'est aussi une
réflexion qui mûrissent et aussi des
événements qui s'accélère
mais c'est aussi ce que je vous dis sur
ce qui s'est passé le weekend dernier
enfin quand même c'est
une
autre
images de la droite dans quelques jours
et dans quelques semaines mais à
l'évidence encore une fois l'extrême
éparpillement l'extrême dispersion de la
gauche et cette accélération
effectivement du débat politique et ce
débat qui se ressemble de plus en plus
cette être
cannibaliser par une droite de plus en
plus extrême et une extrême droite
impose à la gauche et
que vous avez pas l'impression d'avoir
totalement jusqu'à présent je me
souviens qu'en septembre
je me souviens même plus encore plus
longtemps
il y a
vraiment
de la campagne et campagne elle ne fait
que commencer
elle commence quand même depuis depuis
des mois et vous pouvez pas dire que à
l'heure actuelle
pour être organisé
sur les marchés et vous verrez l'intérêt
ou non de nos concitoyens justement pour
cette élection présidentielle et
notamment
la question pour les électeurs de gauche
c'est de créer cette dynamique c'est de
se désespérer face à cet à cet
éparpillant as été par piment et donc si
on ne veut pas être dans le témoignage
et bien oui il faut prendre acte de
cette situation oui il faut faire preuve
de courage et de responsabilités et
je pense que
de la même manière dans les jours et
dans les semaines qui viennent
et qui
a été lancé depuis un certain nombre de
pas une situation
qui est celle que l'on connaît et donc
il va y avoir des discussions il ne
compris
qu'est-ce que vous imaginez
dans les prochaines heures dans les
prochains jours il y aura des
discussions entre les représentants des
partis politiques entre les différents
candidats et les promoteurs de cette
primaire populaire pour voir quel donc
c'est le mien
il faut encore il faut pouvoir élargir
il faut discuter des modalités est-ce
qu' est-ce qu'il y a des hauts de la DDE
électronique est-ce qu'il y a des votre
physique c'est l'ensemble de ces
questions et
encore une fois il faut maintenant
et que il y a une dynamique qui
s'enclenche à gauche face à la situation
est-ce que je pourrais y participer on
parle beaucoup d'elle elle est à Paris
elle est consulte on a l'impression
qu'elle s'interroge est-ce que c'est pas
une manière aussi de lui permettre de
rentrer dans le jeu est l'orage moi je
n'ai pas eu de contact avec elle et donc
j'imagine qu'elle est là elle a une voix
elle elle dira qu'elle a à dire dans les
elle aussi dans les prochaines heures
pour la gauche et
bien
[Musique]
et que chacun de cette situation pour un
nouvel espoir pour permettre de se dire
nous sommes pas là pour témoigner encore
une fois il y a une situation
il y a
location la justice qui est dans un état
est la seule réponse ce serait de
d'écouter les droites et l'extrême
droite pour savoir si il faut supprimer
200000 poste de fonctionnaire comme le
propose Valérie Pécresse de savoir si 25
% 25 % des plus pauvres qui sont morts à
l'âge de 62 ans et c'est une faut
attendre 80 ans pour atteindre la même
proportion chez les plus riches
à 65 ans ou 67 ans et bien non il y a
autre chose que la gauche dois dire dans
cette campagne
de la primaire des républicains vous
avez vu ce qui se passe depuis samedi
est-ce que du coup
est-ce que vous ne pouvez pas
encore une fois de la situation Anne
Hidalgo elle prend acte de la situation
elle pose cet acte de responsabilité en
disant à l'ensemble de la gauche il faut
se rassembler où il faut on ne peut pas
désespérer les électeurs et les actrices
de gauche de ce pays moi je ne crois pas
à cette fariboles que notre pays serait
ce serait droitise et quand on interroge
les Français sur la solidarité sur le
besoin de justice sur la volonté de
lutter contre les inégalités et bien ça
c'est toujours des proportions très
majoritaires les les les inégalités
d'exploser les les Français ne peuvent
plus vivre dignement de leur travail et
la seule réponse ce serait de diminuer
encore les la fiscalité sur les
successions et l'héritage des plus
riches dans ce pays non ça ne peut pas
être ça la réponse aujourd'hui pour
notre pays est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire en tout cas après l'émission de du
20h vous êtes retrouvés vous êtes en
visio je crois avec les autres
parlementaire quel a été son son son
message qu'elle a été comment ça s'est
déroulé est-ce que tout le monde était
d'accord ne serait-ce que ça en tout cas
elle a elle a expliqué sa démarche elle
a effectivement dit à quel point elle
elle souhaitait créer une forme des
électrochocs coussin au sein de la
gauche et
sa démarche de salon nous avons eu des
échanges dans l'après-midi il comprit
même le mardi matin lors des réunions
travail l'ensemble de ces questions ont
pu être échangés et des efforts étaient
au courant mais
l'après-midi il y a eu des échanges
entre les dirigeants les ai fait
d'accord avec
un bureau national extraordinaire été
convoqué hier soir et très
majoritairement la démarche d'Anne
Hidalgo était soutenu par les membres du
bureau national du Parti socialiste pour
dire il
était ce matin même chez un de vos
concurrents pour dire à quel point il
fallait s'engager dans cette démarche il
va pas
encore mais encore une fois chacun voit
bien la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans laquelle surtout
la gauche et donc nous nous voulons pas
en rester là il faut créer de la
dynamique l'élection présidentielle
encore une fois c'est c'est de la
dynamique c'est du mouvement il faut
prendre acte des situations faire preuve
de responsabilité courage pour proposer
de l'espoir à gauche pour proposer de
l'espoir doit se dérouler quand
il faut aller il faut maintenant que les
choses s'organisent le plus vite
possible pour que dès les premières
semaines de l'année de l'année 2022 le
dispositif sois sois caler est rentré
pleinement tous ensemble plus largement
possible dans cette élection
présidentielle pour proposer une offre
alternative au débat des droits me
permet de reposer la question parce que
il me semble importante
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dit a dit non
Fabien Roussel a dit non on attend la
fumée blanche ou noire dans les dans les
prochaines
8 minutes mais très sincèrement si aucun
de ces deux trois personnes et
laissez-moi terminer
ne
peut pas être autre chose
et
on verra bien dans les prochains jours
comment cette situation fait bouger la
gauche fait bouger les
[Musique]
rassemblements
dans le témoignage de ne pas simplement
à qui est à cinq ou six un autre qui a 7
ou 8 et puis le troisième à 8 ou 9 ça ça
ne suffit pas la belle affaire que l'un
d'entre soit à 8 quand l'autre est à
cette quel est l'intérêt quel est
l'intérêt moi quand je me suis engagé
c'est pour changer concrètement la vie
des gens c'est pas pour témoigner quand
dans nos collectivité en
Seine-Saint-Denis à Paris à Nancy à
Montpellier dans le Sud-Ouest ou
ailleurs et bien c'est le rassemblement
de regarder devant soi Hollande hier qui
qui parlait justement de la primaire qui
disait deux écueils c'est que dans une
primaire ça se prépare quand même tu as
anticipe d'une part et deuxièmement il
est rappelé quand même que il fallait
quand même une sorte de socle de socle
commun a minima et il semble quand même
assez difficilement conciliables les
positions entre un Jean-Luc Mélenchon
déjà et une amygdale moi ce que je
constate c'est que Noa lecteur de gauche
ils ne veulent pas entendre de cette
thèse ce n'est pas conciliable dans les
2e tour des locaux tour ou dans le 2e
tour des élections c'est électorat il se
rassemble qu'est-ce qu'ils disent il
faut une réponse aux inégalités qui
explose il faut en finir avec cette
conception de l'hôpital comme une
entreprise et guider simplement par des
objectifs comptable et financier il faut
développer le service public il faut
lutter contre les inégalités sociales et
territoriale et j'entends beaucoup de
différence entre les candidats de gauche
enfin écouter c'est pas sérieux c'est
pas sérieux on va pas continuer
d'observer encore une fois ce débat
politique d'un autre pays s'organiser
autour d'une droit de moins en moins
républicaine de plus en plus extrême et
des extrême droite ça suffit la
République
c'est pas tout à fait la République
mais pour le coup hier il s'est ouvrir
sa candidature a un projet
est-ce que c'est elle doit se faire
uniquement où est-ce que vous êtes prêt
à
partir du moment où
tu
[Musique]
es courageux et
donc maintenant oui il faut que tu
puisses engagé la discussion pour la
plus large possible qui permettent à nos
concitoyens encore une fois de s'engager
de se mobiliser c'est ce qu'ils nous
disent que
l'ensemble de ses déplacements en avec
cette interpellation c'est le cas aussi
pour l'ensemble des nuls nous sommes
nous électeurs nous disent mais il est
temps de vous rassemblez il est temps de
vous venir vous non pas seulement
témoigner et avoir un choix par défaut à
faire au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
qui ne participera pas
je crois que ce n'est pas responsable
de
département qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans les
élections
départementales
de la conférence de presse
expliquer qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
du président de la République sur les
orientations donner à la présidence
française de l'Union européenne je ne
suis pas sûr que nous partions les
partagions avec le président de la
République les mêmes orientation sur ce
que doit être cette présidence française
et l'Union européenne parce que si le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron pour l'Union
européenne finalement c'est
toujours plus la France et l'Union
européenne a des standards de plus en
plus numéro sur la question des services
publics sur la question des retraites
sur la guerre je vous parle pas
très bien mais il faudrait déjà commencé
quand je vois le futur chancelier
allemand qui
engage quand je vois ce qui se passe
dans votre pays notamment au sud de
l'Europe des négociations sur la
question des des
c'est a priori pas la ligne politique et
celle du gouvernement du gouvernement
français et donc c'est ça les
contradictions au moins je prends bien
un certain nombre de déclaration du
président pour de la République pour la
question européennes mais encore
faudrait-il que en France dans notre
pays il ne soit pas celui qui veut y a
man ans alignés finalement notre pays
notre modèle social sur les standards
les plus numéro sur la question de la
retraite sur la question de la fonction
publique sur la question des salaires
enfin qu'est-ce que va dire aujourd'hui
la ministre de la fonction publique aux
organisations syndicales représentatives
des de la fonction publique sur la
question par exemple du point d'indice
des fonctionnaires le salaire des
fonctionnaires est bloqué depuis un
certain nombre d'années dans notre pays
alors même que aujourd'hui il c'est une
question centrale que la question des
salaires d'envoyer ces ses
contradictions entre le live
mais c'est justement les contradictions
à ce que
semble vouloir descendre au sein d'une
question sur la crise sanitaire aussi
autre actualité brûlante le plan blanc
déclenché en Île-de-France il aurait
fallu un tour de vis supplémentaire
selon vous
la situation dans les hôpitaux de de la
région de France et dans mon département
en particulier est particulièrement
préoccupante et donc toutes les mesures
qui permettent de maîtriser la situation
c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que
je suis pour l'obligation de vaccination
je suis pour l'obligation parce que
ça va avec une obligation de moyen pour
la puissance publique ce que je constate
moi je suis pour les scientifiques et
donc ce que je regarde c'est l'évolution
de la situation est l'évolution de la de
la pensée de des préconisations
scientifiques ce que je vous dis
seulement c'est qu'en dépit de tous les
efforts qui ont été notamment dans un
département comme le mien est bien il y
a toujours des écarts et donc il faut
continuer de développer des démarches de
proximité des démarches d'aller vers des
démarches qui permet d'aller chercher ce
qui sont le plus éloigné le moins
connecter le moins le moins bien informé
parce qu'encore une fois et bien les
inégalités elle elle montre à quel point
notre pays est fracturé et donc moi je
ne peux pas me résoudre à cette
situation et donc oui il faut absolument
que le gouvernement stabilise parce que
c'est aussi ça la difficulté c'est qu'à
quelques semaines on nous faisait fermer
les centres de vaccination il faut les
rouvrir en catastrophe il faut compris
le maximum de ce que je pense
parce que là encore et vous ne pouvez
pas en permanence modifier les
organisations une voilà pourquoi
l'obligation de vaccination qui va et
une obligation de moyen pour la
puissance publique sacré de la confiance
sacré de la responsabilité pour chacune
et chacun merci beaucoup merci à vous
d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]